a priori c'est un il y a un problème de
gaz concernant la l'occupant du premier
étage qui était une femme âgée de 88 ans
et qui perdait un peu le sens des
réalités on va dire
on a des témoignages en ce sens ou elle
allumait le gaz pour faire cuire quelque
chose et l'oublier comme ça pendant une
heure deux heures elle savait plus de
l'éteindre en fait elle perdait oui elle
perdait le sens de réalité et le gaz il
faut savoir que c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement vicieux parce que il faut
je suis pas chimiste mais il faut un
mélange très très précis pour que ça
provoque une explosion ça peut fuir
pendant des jours et des jours sans que
ça explose et d'un seul coup parce qu'il
y a le bon mélange ça saute ou alors une
étincelle un frigo qui se remet en route
peut suffire à provoquer l'explosion et
on voit les dégâts que ça a provoqué
alors ce qui est terrible dans cette
histoire c'est que les voisins du
dessous avaient
était sensibilisé à ce problème il lui
avait même acheté à priori une gazinière
électrique
sauf que cette personne âgée elle
voulait pas s'en servir et à la
continuer à vouloir fonctionner avec le
avec le gaz je crois aussi savoir que
les services sociaux ont été avisés de
ce problème et c'est vrai que c'était
pas très compliqué de couper le gaz à
cette dame et on aurait évité
probablement cette terrible catastrophe
pareil par les militaires il vient donc
cette femme de 88 ans dont vous parliez
un instant Antonietta et je vous propose
d'écouter le fils d'une victime qui
estiment que cette dame perdait la tête
ce que vous dites et qui avait je cite
des problèmes avec le gaz depuis
plusieurs plusieurs semaines maintenant
plusieurs mois et c'est vrai que déjà
les habitants sont plaignaient et s'en
inquiéter regardez
mes parents l'entretenaient avec elle
une relation plus amicale
et cette dame perdez la tête elle était
devenue sénile elle mettait la télé à
tuer à telle ça avait plus l'arrêter et
elle avait un problème avec le gaz je
sais que plusieurs fois quand je venais
voir mes parents mon beau-père me disait
tiens j'étais obligé de monter chez
Antoinette parce qu'elle avait mis elle
avait mis la poêle à chauffer pour et
puis elle avait oublié les services
sociaux ont été alertés à priori ça a
été une fin de non recevoir sur ce qui a
été demandé à savoir une mise en
sécurité de l'appartement au niveau du
gaz
voilà donc Michel donc
on voit c'est ce que vous avez expliqué
c'est vrai que là vous dites qu'on
aurait peut-être pu éviter ça à partir
du moment où les services sociaux c'est
quand même un peu leur boulot
sont à visées alors ils vont vous dire
qu'il y a une procédure qu'il faut
prévenir je ne sais qui et je ne sais
quoi et que il faut des je vous dis je
les prends de leurs défenses ils font
déborder il faut leur boulot c'est sûr
mais c'est surtout c'est pas les
services sociaux c'est le système qui
est tellement long et tellement sinueux
au niveau des paperasses etc c'est que à
un moment les gars pour prendre une
décision prenne la décision le temps
qu'ils envoient le truc ça y est ça
explosé 15 fois donc c'est vrai qu'à un
moment il y a ici c'est le problème de
ce pays aussi on en parlait avec la
justice on en parle avec plein de choses
c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est très
très long tout est long donc on le voit
quand il y a des squatteurs c'est ses
lent quand il y a des il y a des
problèmes avec la justice est long quand
il y a des problèmes sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est très long donc à un moment
c'est vrai que long donc aussi alors ils
ont été avertis mais je pense que la
procédure était tellement longue que ça
a fait que ce drame c'est s'est déroulé
alors il y a d'autres témoins et
victimes de l'explosion qui sont
exprimés dans les médias on vous a fait
une compil de leur témoignage regardez
j'ai entendu un groupe et même les
scooters à côté de moi ils ont ils ont
soigné les alarmes ils étaient
déclenchées et tout et je voyais que ça
bougeait et que j'ai fait j'ai fermé
tout de suite l'alimentation je me suis
dit c'est un attentat avec tout ce qui
se passe et tout c'était éprouvant il y
a un instant j'étais j'étais chez moi
d'un coup j'entends un gros boom je
pensais que c'était quoi c'était c'était
un balcon qui s'était écroulé sur une
voiture j'ai rien compris du coup je
vois une avalanche de personnes ça
pouvait dans la rue je vois ma petite
sœur en bas
et là je me mets à courir mais comme pas
possible je me suis approché j'ai
regardé et là j'ai vu le les éboulis et
l'immeuble qui essaient
vous avoue je suis un peu choquée là
alors quatre décis corps extraits de
l'effondrement de cet immeuble ont
désormais été identifié il s'agit donc
de Jacques et Anne-Marie un homme de 74
ans et sa femme du même âge et Nicole et
anthonetta donc c'est responsable de
femme à gérer respectivement de 65 et 88
ans c'est ce qu'a annoncé le procureur
de Marseille on ne sait pas encore
l'identité et de dernier corps pour
l'instant non on n'a pas l'identité des
deux derniers corps il y a des
recherches qui sont en cours mais il
suffit que ce soit des personnes un
petit peu isolées parce que pour les
identifier formellement il faut faire
une vérification ADN et donc une
comparaison c'est à dire qu'il y a des
enfants des petits-enfants une lignée
maternelle ou paternelle et a priori ils
sont à la recherche de de parents qui
pourraient
permettre de faire la comparaison ADN a
priori ils sont identifiés
officieusement mais tant qu'on n'a pas
la certitude par l'ADN
on ne peut pas dire qu'on les a
identifiés alors
c'était dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche il est 0h46 lorsqu'une énorme
déflagration retentit dans le cinquième
arrondissement de Marseille l'immeuble
mitoyen le numéro 19 est éventré sur les
réseaux sociaux il y a deux jeunes
hommes qui étaient situés à deux
endroits différents de la ville qui
était en train de se filmer lorsque
l'explosion a eu lieu
au revoir
il y a plusieurs vidéos des dégâts et
des secours sur place qui ont été
partagés regardez ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
explose
c'est incroyable c'est vrai que c'est
des scènes qui font froid dans le dos
oui Gilles tout de suite l'explosion du
yoga a été privilégiée parce qu'il y a
d'abord le bruit de l'explosion et les
gens autour ont été ce qu'on appelle
blastet c'est à dire que le gaz fait que
vous avez une compression pulmonaire et
ce qui est encore plus dramatique c'est
que le deuxième et troisième étage de
l'immeuble avait été neutralisé au
niveau du gaz il restait plus que les
deux étages d'en bas qui étaient
alimentés au gaz et des gens ont fait
tout de suite leur rapprochement qui est
faux avec ce qui s'est passé en 2018
vous souvenez la rue d'Aubagne à
Marseille 8 morts mais là c'est un
immeuble insalubre cet immeuble n'avait
jamais été mis en péril il y a un
problème avec pas de problème pas
d'arrêter donc vraisemblablement c'est
le gaz qui a provoqué l'explosion voilà
alors une enquête est en cours
voilà les premières conclusions voilà on
les connaît
enfin faut qu'elle soit officielle
maintenant et la police judiciaire a
beaucoup de mal à travailler dans ce sur
ce terrain tant que les pompiers tant
que les les secouristes sont sur place
il y a priori peu de chance
malheureusement de retrouver des gens
vivants dans ces dans ces décombres mais
s'il y a ne serait-ce qu'une chance de
retrouver une personne vivante il faut
tout mettre en œuvre pour pour y arriver
il veut de la Vieille Dame a dit que
justement antonetta n'était pas du tout
sénile lui la défend évidemment en
disant qu'elle avait absolument aucun
problème
mais en tout cas sont le fils des
occupants du rez-de-chaussée
le fils dit le contraire et de toute
façon ça ne peut a priori pas être autre
chose qu'une explosion de gaz donc il y
a déjà les deux étages du haut qui qui
sont neutralisées au rez-de-chaussée les
gens
a priori ils sont pas en cause donc ça
vient du premier état
les enquêteurs ont pris le compteur de
ce justement de cette dame pour voir
s'il y a une utilisation excessive pour
voir s'il y avait si c'était une fuite
enfin voilà l'enquête est en cours quoi
l'identité judiciaire fera son travail
c'est c'est un travail de la police
technique et scientifique ils sont ils
sont spécialisés pour ce type de
d'investigation mais pour l'instant il y
a trop de gravats il y a trop de il y a
trop de de
dégâts il faut dégager tout ça et après
ça sera le temps de l'enquête